[Musica]
questa sono io 12 agosto 2013 a san
diego california durante il viaggio
della maturità
mare sole e vento un sorriso se non la
conoscesse dovessi descrivere questa
immagine probabilmente usare il termine
spensieratezza ecco e lo userei il
proprio se non la conoscesse perché
quello che non si vede in questa foto è
che questa ragazza aveva alle spalle
mesi di esami e un ricovero in ospedale
proprio poco prima della partenza
un'altra cosa che non si vede che
probabilmente non vedeva neanche la
ragazza nella foto è che una volta
rientrata in italia avrebbe ricevuto la
diagnosi di sclerosi multipla
bella batosta a 18 anni e tante tante
paure e inizia così la mia vita in
università e con la diagnosi un po in
contemporanea in cui però mi rendo conto
che io non parlo di questa cosa perché
anche se i sintomi ci sono non si vede
niente quindi non mi sentivo
giustificata a farlo poi va beh non è
che sia un argomento che esce davanti
alla macchinetta del caffè se quest'anno
suonato al mare tu beh mi hanno
diagnosticato una malattia
neurodegenerativa
acqui da oggi non c'è cura
classico rapporto davanti alla
macchinetta del caffè passano gli anni
nel 2018 qualcosa dentro di me scatta e
mi rendo conto che in tutto quel tempo
io ho sempre cercato qualcosa qualcuno
con cui potermi confrontare o anche solo
con cui poter parlare e non ho mai
trovato nessuno e decido che non può
essere così che non voglio che un'altra
persona non diagnosticata debba patire
la solitudine e debba avere le stesse
paure che ho avuto io apro quindi il
canale youtube giornate di sclero dove
condivido la mia esperienza con la sm
per creare consapevolezza perché alla
patologia ma faccio anche dei video su
che cos'è la sclerosi multipla perché io
volevo anche creare informazione per chi
magari non la conosce o pensa di
conoscerle si basa solo sugli stereotipi
inizia a mettere i piccoli mattoncini
per creare una vera e propria community
da youtube passò poi a di instagram e da
lì
l'impegno vero la sensibilizzazione
l'attivismo e la condivisione diventano
parte di me e mi danno modo non solo di
arrivare a tante persone ma anche di
capire molto della mia patologia mi
rendo conto che tante azioni tanti
pensieri che ho avuto negli anni
precedenti sono frutti del mio abili
smente realizzato per chi non lo sapesse
la bellismo si descrive come la
discriminazione nei confronti delle
persone con disabilità o più in generale
il presupporre che tutte le persone
abbiano un corpo abile questo si dice
interiorizzato quando questi meccanismi
di esclusione vengono messi un po come
autosabotaggio in atto direttamente
dalle persone con disabilità ce l'hanno
mi faccio qualche esempio nei primi anni
della diagnosi io sforzavo il mio corpo
perché volevo essere una normale ragazza
di 18 anni poi normalità non si sa bene
che cosa sia e quindi mi sono lasciata
fuori corso e sono laureata fuori corso
perchè due giorni a settimana io stavo
male per gli effetti collaterali dei
farmaci che facevo ma testarda
orgogliosa comunque pianificava che in
cui due giorni a sarei stata in grado di
studiare quei due giorni arrivavano io
ero uno zombie nel letto e divano e
ovviamente non riuscivo a studiare il
senso di colpa veniva fuori non passavo
gli esami e senso di colpa ovviamente
aumentano in modo esponenziale
e poi con i miei amici mi rendo conto
che portavo il mio corpo davvero al
limite per uscire con loro anche se ero
stravolta pur di non dire che ero stanca
perché non volevo essere scusa non
volevo essere additata come la vittima
perché alla fine non si vede niente
a volte è più difficile convivere con la
società che con la patologia e ricordo
ancora la frase fissa in tutte le mie
relazioni
guarda che se peggioro ti lascio io
dovevo avere il controllo su questo
perché non potevo permettere che la
persona accanto a me che amavo
rinunciasse la sua vita pur di starmi
accanto è un pensiero tremendo ma io lo
credevo veramente e non vi nascondo che
a volte lo penso ancora perché la bit ma
interiorizzato e subdolo per quanto tu
ci possa lavorare ogni tanto ritorna
e a volte vorrei semplicemente che la
patologia si vedesse un pochino un
pochino di più per non sentire lo
sguardo di giudizio e dubbioso di quando
vado al botteghino del cinema a chiedere
un biglietto ridotto per persone con
disabilità ricordo ancora due anni fa
quando l'ho fatto per la prima volta mi
sentivo sporca
sporca richiedere quei due euro di
riduzione sul biglietto perché non si
vede niente quindi vero portava dietro
un faldone con i siti di risonanze esami
visite perché avevo bisogno di tutto il
supporto materiale possibile per far
valere un mio diritto
anche se in realtà lo sentivo un po come
un dovermi giustificare
ed ero molto indecisa se condividere o
meno questa cosa sui social perché mi
vergognavo cioè proprio io che facevo
attivismo che avevo paura di far valere
un mio diritto per il giudizio esterno
e qui mi rendo conto veramente della
potenza della condivisione condivido
tremante questo video e non ricevo mai
così tanti messaggi come in quel momento
persone che magari avevano un invalidità
riconosciuta dallo stato ma dato che non
si vedeva niente non sapevano neanche di
poter accedere a questa agevolazione
o altre persone che erano ben
consapevoli ma non lo facevano per
favore del giudizio per paura di doversi
giustificare ma vedendo il mio video
hanno trovato il coraggio di farlo anche
loro e quando mi raccontano queste
esperienze la sento in piccola parte un
po come anche una mia vittoria io vado
ancora a chiedere quel biglietto al
botteghino e tremo ancora però meno
perché so di non essere sola ed è
proprio in questo momento che mi rendo
conto che aver creato quel progetto
giornate di sclero nel 2018 sia stata
una delle cose migliori della mia vita
perché riesco a toccare con mano il bene
che riesce a portare
certo è che questi pensieri noi non è
che l'interno realizziamo perché ci
piace ma perché veniamo cresciuti in un
contesto che ci porta a pensare
determinate cose se vediamo una persona
in sedia a rotelle ci viene quasi
normale pensare poverina
però voglio vedere se a quella persona
fa piacere essere compatito in quel modo
o magari essere innalzata alla grande e
guerriera quando sta solo facendo la
spesa
la condivisione non deve e non può
passare solo per le persone con
disabilità
deve cambiare la diffidenza il giudizio
è soprattutto il pregiudizio che c'è
verso disabilità come la mia che sono
chiamate spesso invisibili appunto
perché non si vede niente
ma non lo sono davvero lo sembra non
perché si parte dal presupposto che
tutti i corpi sono abili ma sono
invisibili da te perché se ci fosse la
reale possibilità di una condivisione di
una fragilità ci si renderebbe ben conto
della loro presenza diventano invisibili
date quando al saio la sclerosi multipla
ci viene risposto ma dai non si vede
niente neanche sempre è malata oppure
c'è di peggio
o quando condividiamo un sintomo
invisibile
beh anche io non sono un fiore è però
mica mi lamento ho ancora gaia alla
scampagnata non invitiamo la poi magari
si stanca e la mettiamo in difficoltà
ecco questa azione benevola che può
sembrare benevole in realtà sa solamente
attuando un'esclusione perché ancor
prima di partire con l'ascolto noi siamo
già al giudizio e magari in questo
contesto può sembrare superficiale ma
proviamo a metterli in ambito aziendale
no lui da quel cliente importante non
mandiamolo perché se poi sei si stanca
con lo stress magari la performance ne
risentisse capite il peso sociale e poi
potenzialmente economico che a questa
esclusione
o ancora quando in commissione medica mi
hanno detto lei è reattiva e di bella
presenza ci sembra indipendente il che
cosa è venuto a fare qua
ero tornata invisibile
tutti questi che vi ho elencato sono
veramente pensieri e comportamenti abili
sti perché non danno spazio all'ascolto
fanno spazio solo a giudizio ma la
disabilità è veramente così lontana da
noi da doverla marginalizzare a
prescindere perché qualcosa di diverso
facciamo un gioco
chiedo a tutti voi di alzarvi in piedi
per chi notoriamente non può farlo
basterà alzare una mano
ok ottimo
seguite le indicazioni chiunque abbia un
invalidità riconosciuta dallo stato una
patologia che magari ancora non è stata
riconosciuta può sedersi
e io già le vedo le persone che magari
hanno qualcuno accanto che sei seduto
dire ma chissà che cosa
e normale ha un pensiero normale perché
noi storicamente semi improntati a
questo pensiero perché inconsciamente
associamo la parola diverso
a tutto ciò che è pericoloso che quando
andavamo a cacciare per sopravvivere ci
stava come pensiero ci stava forse oggi
un po meno tutto sta in come vogliamo
superare noi questa atavica paura del
diverso pro andiamo avanti
chiunque porti gli occhiali o lenti a
contatto si può sedere
equa mezza fa la sparisce può sembrarvi
strano ma altro non sono che un semplice
ausilio per una disabilità visiva più o
meno marcata
chiunque sia o sia mai stato un
caregiver o si sia mai preso cura abbia
supportato una persona con disabilità
amico parente conoscente si può sedere
chiunque si sa mai rotto un arto o abbia
fatto un intervento chirurgico che ha
portato a un periodo di convalescenza si
può sedere
per quelle poche persone che sono
rimaste in piedi vi svelo un segreto
sicuramente anche voi in vecchie reti e
con molta probabilità rientrerete in una
delle situazioni precedenti
vi ho appena dimostrato che la
disabilità non è così lontana da noi
come la immaginiamo perché ne abbiamo
così tanta paura quando prima parlavamo
di lavorare sull'inclusione non lo
stiamo facendo per chissà chi lo stiamo
facendo per noi
è un cambiamento culturale in cui siamo
tutti coinvolti
perché se vivessimo in un mondo in cui
non ci sono barriere strutturali in
termini di accessibilità
geografica lavorativa sociale e un sedia
rotelle fosse veramente considerata alla
stregua
degli occhiali ne avremo ancora così
tanta paura
se la nostra società non fosse così
improntata sulla performance e ad andare
sempre al cento per cento e ci fosse la
reale possibilità di condivisione di una
fragilità avremo ancora paura di alzare
la mano e chiedere aiuto quando ne
sentiamo il bisogno
quando condividiamo la nostra esperienza
la nostra patologia veniamo minimizzati
e giudicati ecco se questo non
succedesse ne avremo ancora paura di
parlare
ne dubito ne dubito perché saremmo tutti
inseriti in un contesto in cui non
importa che specificità tu abbia o
quanto diverso tu sia ti saranno
comunque date tutte le opportunità
prescindere a questo cambio culturale ci
vede tutti i protagonisti quindi cosa
potete fare voi oggi per cambiare le
regole del gioco
mettetevi ancora in ascolto delle
persone con disabilità come avete appena
fatto che vuol dire ascolto niente
giudizio vi capiterà ancora di pensare
che sa che cosa questo ma sono sicura
che da oggi in poi quando avrete quel
pensiero riuscirete a declinare in
maniera differente perché ne capirete la
radice senza minimizzare
quello che per voi può sembrare un
granello di sabbia nella vita di
qualcuno può pesare un macigno
e ascolto senza pietismo perché vi posso
assicurare che una poverina non ha mai
fatto apparire magicamente una rampa ci
sono delle scale inaccessibili ascolto
vi assicuro che abbiamo ancora
tantissimo di cui parlare insieme
potremo realmente parlare di inclusione
grazie
[Applauso]